all right 6 25 on your Friday morning  boy it was a great night for one of  eight news now's Community Pride  Partners the other night  resource and support network and you're  here to help and we thank you  one of the honorees at the collaboration  Center foundation's second annual night  on block Michelle de Rocher introduced  by her boss Tyler quarter from the  Findlay automotive group whenever  someone meets Michelle  they instantly have a better day the 34  year old with Down Syndrome showed her  thanks by signing a song  [Music]  oh man Tyler's right Michelle brings a  smile to your face all right  collaboration Center Foundation  president and CEO Linda touche tells me  the event raised a little over 500  thousand dollars to continue their  mission at the beautiful five acre ranch  in the southwest Valley congrats also to  honor to other honorees the former Las  Vegas mayor Jan Jones blackhurst and her  husband Dana